ta madame thuan bora pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre devant
le drame de rambouillet qui me touche
particulièrement et qui résonne comme un
nouvel appel à tuer du flic devant les
policiers visés par des tirs de mortiers
souvent victimes de guet-apens les
émeutes à valence limoges roman
villefranchois encore tourcoing nos
forces de l'ordre incrédule tiennent le
front devant une nouvelle école incendié
à lille et des pompiers attaqué lors de
leur intervention devant des élus
sauvagement agressé encore dernièrement
le maire de poissy pris pour cible nos
forces de l'ordre incrédule tiennent le
front devant les black blocks qui
s'infiltrent dans les cortèges des
manifestations pour piétiner la
démocratie sociale devant des voyous
arrêté qui ricanent sachant qu'ils
seront relâchés le jour même
nos forces de l'ordre incrédule tiennent
le ferons quand les obligations de
quitter le territoire ne sont pas
exécutées que vous rétorquer que
l'immigration n'a rien à voir avec la
politique de sécurité nos forces de
l'ordre incrédule tiennent le ferons
quand ils aspirent à plus de
reconnaissance vous créer une plate
forme de signalement des discriminations
qui stigmatise le travail de nos
policiers nos forces de l'ordre
incrédule tiennent le front les forces
de l'ordre expriment aujourd'hui leur
fatigue devant le renoncement de l'état
une nation qui ne soutient pas ceux qui
se battent pour elle courra la bim ma
question est donc simple que comptez
vous faire pour restaurer l'autorité de
l'état est ainsi réhabiliter nos forces
de l'ordre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame marlène schiappa
ministre délégué chargé de la
citoyenneté j'ai vu monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice thuan
pourra d'abord comme l'a fait monsieur
le premier ministre à l'heure de la
cérémonie à rambouillet et comme l'a
fait précédemment monsieur le président
du sénat je veux évidemment rendre
hommage ici devant vous à stéphanie
cette policière qui a été sauvagement
assassinés dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions alors qu'elle servait son pays
au commissariat de rambouillet depuis 28
ans était un des visages de notre police
un visage de celles et ceux qui au
quotidien protège et vous avez raison le
rappeler il est de notre devoir de
protéger ceux qui protègent et avec
gérald a maintenant au ministère de
l'intérieur c'est le sens de l'action
que nous menons avec les forces de
l'ordre c'est pour cela que nous avons
souhaité ici même faire voter un budget
en augmentation historique pour la
sécurité et je vous remercie d'ailleurs
de l'avoir votée en constatant que ce
budget était en augmentation forte et en
augmentation historique c'est aussi pour
cela qu'avec le ministre de l'intérieur
nous voulons mieux doter les policiers
parce que respecter les policiers
respecter les gendarmes c'est aussi
respecter leur travail et c'est leur
permettre d'avoir le matériel nécessaire
qu'il s'agisse de tenus qu'il s'agissent
de vidéoprotection et c'est l'engagement
du ministre de l'intérieur lors de tous
ses déplacements auprès des élus et vous
le savez comme gérald darmanin l'a
rappelé d'ailleurs avec gravité malgré
le travail exceptionnel des services de
renseignement français qui ont déjoué 35
attentats depuis janvier 2017 et que je
veux ici saluer malgré le recrutement
dès 1900 policiers supplémentaires dans
les services de renseignement malgré le
doublement du budget de la dgs si malgré
les textes anti terroristes qui sont
votées quinquennat après quinquennat et
bien malgré cela oui notre pays est
toujours la cible à la fois du
terrorisme islamiste mais aussi de
menaces et de violence forte est il
admissible contre les forces de l'ordre
j'étais hier à la gare saint-lazare
auprès des forces de l'ordre pour leur
assurer de notre plein soutien du
soutien du gouvernement
les policiers et les gendarmes sont en
première ligne ce sont eux qui protège
nos concitoyens les actes c'est
important c'est pourquoi nous avons
lancé le bobo de la sécurité et dans ce
but de la sécurité le ministre de
l'intérieur écoute chacun c'est pourquoi
nous avons présenté la loi pour la
sécurité globale qui permet de renforcer
la protection vis-à-vis de ses pôles y
conclut claire et sans aucune ambiguïté
le gouvernement soutient pleinement et
sans réserve l'action des forces de
l'ordre qui sont la police de la
république merci merci
madame bois je compte sur vous pour
transmettre à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur que je n'ai fait que relayer
la vive inquiétude formulée par les
policiers sur le terrain comprendre le
malaise de cette profession c'est oser
regarder dans le miroir un miroir qui
renvoie l'image d'un état dépasser
submergées nos policiers demandent à
leurs enfants de cacher leur profession
ils craignent pour leur sécurité pour
celle de leurs familles au rythme actuel
restera-t-il des candidats pour postuler
ou métier de policiers ou de gendarmes
et alors que ferons nous pour nous que
ferons nous pour combler les effectifs
la sécurité de notre pays comme il est
mieux que des rustines merci
la parole est maintenant à madame
martine filleul pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre la crise sanitaire a mis en
exergue les failles de notre système de
santé en particulier le manque de
personnel médical à l'hôpital comme en
libéral les femmes on souffre plus que
les hommes c'est ainsi que 30 % des
françaises ne bénéficie pas d'un suivi
gynécologique
cela est notamment dû à la quasi
disparition de la gynécologie médicale
libérale ce sont donc 23 mille
sages-femmes et maïeuticien qui assurent
de nombreuses missions liées à
l'accouchement à la contraception ou
encore aux ivg mais ce métier attire de
moins en moins surtout en milieu
hospitalier en raison de la pénibilité
et de la faible rémunération pour
illustration seulement 1 euros 0,7 de
majoration par heure de travail la nuit
la faible revalorisation obtenu lors du
ségur de la santé la loi vise améliorer
le système de santé n'ont pas rassuré la
profession vous les avez d'ailleurs
compte